Unless there is a lead-lined refrigerator
lying around, we’re guessing none of you
reading this would be too keen on standing
at ground zero of a nuclear blast.
But it turns out this is exactly what six
men chose to do with their afternoon in July
of 1957- five of them even volunteered, with
the sixth not told what he’d be ordered
to do that day until he showed up to work…
So who were these men, why were they there,
and what happened after?
As the Cold War began heating up and the U.S.
and Soviets were each attempting to set a
record for money spent stock piling thousands
of weapons not intended to be used, the general
public were getting a little nervous about
both the testing of said weapons and what
would happen if one of the two super powers
decided to take things to the next level,
particularly as rockets and missiles tipped
with nukes started to become a thing.
Despite assertions that there was nothing
inherently dangerous about a rocket with a
nuclear warhead detonating directly above
you, the citizens of the United States weren’t
buying it.
Putting their money where their mouths were,
Colonel Arthur Oldfield of the Continental
Air Defense Command decided to prove the assertion,
ordering to have just this sort of thing filmed
happening.
This particular test, named John, was a part
of the five month long Operation Plumbbob
series of nuclear tests.
Besides the men involved with John, these
tests also included over 18,000 other members
of the military being put in relatively close
proximity to nuclear blasts, with the point
being to determine how troops would react
in battle with nukes detonating nearby.
The tests also included over a thousand pigs
being used to study the biological effects
of the detonations when the subjects were
much closer to the blasts than officials were
comfortable putting humans.
(Squeal piggy!!!)
The
five men who volunteered to insert themselves
into John were Colonel Sidney Bruce, Lt. Colonel
Frank P. Ball, Major Norman “Bodie” Bodinger,
Major John Hughes, and Colonel Donald Lutrell.
The sixth individual was a cameraman named
Akira “George” Yoshitake- simultaneously
the only one who did not volunteer for the
gig and the only one who had a job to do during
the blast.
His job, of course, was to capture the entire
event for a nice little propaganda film to
demonstrate that these nuclear tipped rockets
were perfectly safe to use in air combat scenarios
above populated regions.
And so it was that on July 19, 1957, the five
exceptionally brave men and one cameraman,
no doubt re-evaluating his career choices
and decision making paradigm, found themselves
standing around 70 miles northwest of Las
Vegas as the crow flies, or about 100 miles
by road, in the Yucca Flats in the Area 10
Test Site.
Next to them was a sign that read “Ground
Zero.
Population 5”, casually disregarding the
key contributions of Yoshitake, which has
been a theme for the few hundred filmmakers
who were so critical to these nuclear tests
and data gathering, yet have been largely
ignored by history.
Soon enough an F-28 jet flew overhead, shooting
a Genie rocket equipped with a 1.5 kiloton
W25 nuclear warhead.
This was actually the first test of a live
nuclear tipped Genie rocket, but, thankfully
for the men, the unguided rocket did not malfunction
and instead flew straight for about two and
a half miles at a height of around Flight
Level 180 (about 18,000 feet or about 5.5
km).
It then detonated almost directly above them.
Said Major Bodey as it happened, “We felt
a heat pulse.
A very bright light.
A fireball it is red.
The sky looks black about it.
It is boiling above us.
It is rapidly losing its color…”
Then a massive blast sound could be heard,
at which point Bodey stated, “There is the
ground wave!
It is over folks, It happened!
The mounds are vibrating.
It is tremendous!
Directly above our heads!
It is a huge fireball.
… Wasn’t that a perfect, perfect shot.”
Seemingly remembering the whole thing was
to be a propaganda film showing it was just
good family fun to stand under a nuclear blast,
Colonel Bruce then stated, “My only regrets
right now are that everyone couldn’t have
been out here at ground zero with us.”
Shortly thereafter he no doubt thanked the
Academy and noted he felt humbled to be there.
You might at this point be thinking that while
the blast itself didn’t do them any harm,
other than maybe a stubborn case of tinnitus-
the little talked about silent killer associated
with nuclear blasts- surely these men must
have been exposed to copious amounts of ionizing
radiation.
But this turns out not to have been the case.
It was later determined they were exposed
to negligible amounts of such radiation.
In fact, less than the pilot of the F-89 jet
and significantly less than the pilots ordered
to fly through the region of atmosphere the
blast occurred at a mere ten minutes later.
The blast occurring reasonably high in the
atmosphere also ensured that no ground materials
were sucked up, thus no large cloud of radioactive
particles was present.
And as for the radioactive materials from
the bomb and any dust already in the atmosphere
nearby, these would have spread out quite
widely before coming down.
Ironically, however, while the whole thing
was meant to show the safety of such nuclear
rockets detonating high over head, radioactive
particles from these tests frequently settled
on nearby towns, even as far away as Utah.
As you might expect from this, the U.S. government
has paid a pretty penny, to the tune of around
a billion dollars to date, to the inhabitants
of these regions who later had health problems
possibly related to being exposed to high
amounts of ionizing radiation during the tests.
All this said, it is noted that every one
of these six brave men did later in life get
cancer at one point or another.
However, it’s not thought this test in particularly
probably contributed much to that.
All of them were involved in a number of nuclear
tests, many of which saw them exposed to far
more ionizing radiation, with the cumulative
effect of it all probably also not helping
matters.
In the end, Major Hughes lived to the age
of 71, dying of cancer in 1990.
Lt. Col. Ball lived until 2003, dying at the
ripe old age of 83 of cancer.
Colonel Bruce actually made it to 86, dying
in 2005 of, you guessed it, cancer.
Major Bodinger also died of cancer, we believe
in February of 1997, though it’s not clear
here as his grave is not listed in the U.S.
Department of Veteran Affairs grave site locator.
But we found a grave in Oklahoma for someone
that appears to match up with what we know
about Bodie.
Next up, Colonel Lutrell at one point got
colon cancer, though it isn’t clear whether
this is what he died of.
Whatever the case, he seems to have shuffled
off this mortal coil in 2014 at the age of
91.
As for the cameraman George Yoshitake, while
he did have to battle stomach cancer to do
it, he lived to 84, dying
in 2013 of
a stroke.